tunnel to the quantum realm to my mom
hey everybody it's Charlie I got a lot
of requests to do a video about the end
of ant-man and the wasp so if you
haven't seen it yet careful for spoilers
we'll be talking about the timeline
between the end of a man of the wasp and
the beginning of Avengers 4 and how
they're gonna use a certain character to
open up Avengers 4 so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel and all
the Comic Con videos this week it's
gonna be crazy there'll be new giveaway
stuff at the end of the video - first
big thing a man in the wasp post-credits
scene Scott Lang gets stuck in the
quantum realm I've already done a couple
videos about what's going on down in
there but there were a couple moments
that foreshadowed how he would get out
of the quantum realm and there are a
couple ways that Marvel tells stories
particularly during infinity war that
let you know how they're gonna handle
certain explainers because infinity war
had a whole bunch of cliffhangers for a
bunch of different characters not just
the snap sure they also have Ironman
stranded on Titan with nebula you have
all the people in Wakanda that just lost
their king sure he's the next in line
for that banner still can't Hulk out
Captain America and Thor don't really
have cliffhangers they're just sitting
there in grief and shock like they see
their friends fade away they're not sure
what to do next so under normal
circumstances you would expect the next
movie to pick up in the moments right
after this and they would explain what
the characters do right after this how
does Iron Man get back to earth how to
Cherie start managing Wakanda when does
she actually get crown does she have to
go through a version of the warrior fall
sequence like T'Challa did when he was
crowned king during the Black Panther
movie so you got all these cliffhangers
but the beauty of what Marvel has been
doing for the last couple of movies has
been trying to subvert superhero movie
tropes so instead of spending a half an
hour explaining what each of these
characters does right after this moment
in Avengers 4 I think they're gonna
treat it in a very infinity war way so
what happened at the beginning of
infinity war when all the characters met
up in the sanctum sanctorum there was
all this history
it happens in civil war Boehner had been
on Sekar for quite a long time fighting
as the Hulk but they just sort of washed
right over that with a couple sentences
of dialogue tell me his name again
Thanos he's a plague Tony he invades
planets he takes what he wants he wipes
out half the population
he said Loki the attack on New York
that's him
went down situations totally
screwed so Bruce Banner tells him you
better unscrew things it doesn't matter
who you're not talking to call them up
the world is about to end really only a
couple beats of dialogue before you get
to that big opening action scene with
the Black Order so that's probably the
same thing they're gonna do at the
beginning of Avengers 4 but what is the
most rewarding way to do that Scott Lang
coming out of the quantum realm in the
future
thank you very much random time for to
see his courtesy of Janet Van Dyne so
there's a whole lot of stuff going down
in the quantum realm there's a quantum
city in the background when Hank went to
go get Janet obviously meant to be a
really big easter egg but I don't think
that they're gonna deal with that till
we get to the next ant-man the wasp
movie you really only need that quantum
energy that Scott has and he's already
got it so it's not like he needs to go
to the quantum city and get this big
long explainer about it and then come
out of the quantum realm like he could
just come out science Bros can figure
out how to use the energy so until we
get some footage I say early prediction
is is that Scott Lang opens up the movie
accidentally falling into a time
vortices one of his superpowers is good
luck but not that good luck he comes out
but he comes out a couple years into the
future without realizing it so two
really big surprises first one where the
hell did Janet Hope and Hank Pym go
he thinks that they've disappeared so he
tries to look for them he also wants to
find his daughter so second big surprise
and this is really why I think it's more
rewarding to open the movie with Scott
Lang is that when he goes to see Cassie
he passes out from surprise when he
finds that she's like 16 years old what
the hell happened and then Cassie can be
like where have you been all these years
so like I said instead of spending in
the first half hour of Avengers 4
explaining what all these characters do
next you just use Scott Lang to jump out
of the quantum realm ago what the hell
is going on why is everybody older what
happened the last couple of years so he
learns about
snap sure then goes to track down the
Avengers and you have a couple brief
conversations where they have sort of
that sanctum type of dialogue explaining
what happened to them since the events
of infinity war Ironman made it off of
Titan a long time ago Thor has been
trying to help his people set up new
Asgard they call it as Gardea there were
about 50% of the people that were on
this ship at the end of thor ragnarok
that survived they were going to Norway
to set up new Asgard so that's probably
what he's been doing since the end of
the movie but everybody has been
destroyed in their grief like visibly
aging many years beyond what they should
normally look like so like Iron Man
looks like he put on about ten years
worth of city miles one of the reasons
why people think that his suit has not
changed at the beginning of Avengers 4
it's all similar in all this concept art
is because he's so grief-stricken he
can't move forward think about how crazy
he went after the events of the first
Avengers film they didn't really deal
with that till Iron Man 3
check the heart check that check that is
the brain no sign of cardiac anomaly or
unusual brain activity so imagine that
only 10 times worse now because half of
all life in the universe was destroyed
so next big prediction is as the Scott
still has the quantum energy with him
he's not a scientist he doesn't really
know how it works there's some accident
and Iron Man gets an idea wait a minute
you have quantum energy how the hell did
you get that maybe we can use that you
get a science Bros montage and they
create those risk devices that we've
seen in all the behind the scenes
pictures that the Russos were talking
about so when people ask them about
these photos they said this is something
that's similar to what you saw during
civil war
meaning the be AR effing technology they
didn't deny multiple universes or any
outright time-travel so it looks like
what might be happening is is the Iron
Man combines his barfing technology with
the quantum energy and they use that to
sort of hack their minds and stitch
together aspects of different realities
so there's still a whole lot of
questions that aren't answered like we
don't know how captain Marvel's powers
are gonna be different from the comics
and how she's going to change the group
dynamic what she's actually going to be
doing during the movie like if she's
just gonna go and fight Thanos is she
gonna have something else to do I'd
recommend waiting to theory craft about
her until they dropped that first
trailer because once you learned what
her new powers are like if she has
mysterious quantum realm based powers -
that would be very different from comic
book Captain Marvel so obviously none of
this says how they fixed the universe
all it is is just how Scott Lang gets
out of the quantum realm and how they
open up Avengers 4 so let me know in the
comments what do you think the first 15
minutes or so of Avengers 4 is going to
be like like is it just gonna open with
a time jump are we gonna see that
through Scott Lang's character the
beauty of ant-man is that he's sort of
like a c-3po r2d2 type character that
you can use to drive the plot forward
because one of his superpowers is good
luck he falls ass-backwards into
situations that you can use to drive the
plot forward so just imagine ant-man not
a scientist not fully understanding the
complexities of the quantum realm
falling ass-backwards into a time
or Tech's coming out in them using that
to drive the plot forward and Avengers
for like oh my god everything's
different hey I have this quantum energy
maybe we can do something with this just
a reminder about comic-con I will make a
new playlist at the top of my channel
where I'll put all of the Comic Con
videos just to make it easier to find
but Marvel Studios isn't doing a hall H
panel that doesn't mean that they won't
surprise us with some announcements but
the real Marvel stuff that's happening
is all spider-man venom stuff that's
gonna be Friday night I'll just remind
people about the video schedule as I
post new videos so I have a pretty good
idea of what the week is gonna look like
but leave all your requests in the
comments below we're still doing that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video click
here to watch Tom Hall and give away
some of the plot of Avengers 4 it's
great and click here for all my ant-man
and the wasp Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you